let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well welcome to our special guest
episode
we got a lot of things we're gonna hash
out
and there's a couple fellers from
indiana
that i would like to talk about so i'm
bringing on
a special neighbor of theirs
you guys have
seen their neighbor on this show before
mr jimmy kennedy
of the no castler podcast he's our
special guest today so we're going to
get to that but i want to talk about the
topics that we're going to cover because
this is very important and i want to
tell you what's going on we're going to
air this on friday
but today today is tuesday
the 14th and uh there's an election
going on in california so i'm sure me
and jimmy will touch on that uh it's a
recall election we're trying to see if
uh who's gonna be who's gonna be the
governor out there which i'm sure by the
end of the night we'll have some results
but we'll find out we'll find out so so
i'm sure we'll get to that topic but
also we want to talk about uh general
mark milley
stepping in and telling trump get your
hands off the newts
you [ __ ] buffoon
so i'm sure we'll get to that story as
well but the main reason why i wanted to
bring jimmy on is because jimmy
jimmy's met
the former vice president mike pence
before he's got a couple different uh
stories about mike pence but so i wanted
to get his his indiana
opinion
on
on his fellow hoosiers over there
on how mike pence called
called the former vice president dan
quayle so we're gonna bring jimmy on and
and get uh get his opinion here let's
bring jimmy in hey jimmy how are you
buddy tony what's going on dude thanks
for having me oh well i i wanted like i
said uh
these indiana boys showed up in this uh
in the news today so i figured i'd get
someone from indiana on here to
and uh no one better than jimmy kennedy
the producer of the no cancer podcast so
thanks for joining us buddy of course
man how have you been down there is it
that good weather bad weather what's
going on huh uh like like most of the
united states it's it's very swampy you
know it's not on fire like california
but it's very swampy hotter than [ __ ]
huh
yeah i mean we're in mid-september and i
it's it's still a drench yesterday most
days so but you know climate change is a
hoax right you know that's why
you know the midwest will be the last to
go that's if there's any benefit to it
it's that it's still habitable at this
point i guess i guess we'll we'll be
warm as we'll be warm as [ __ ] crowded
as [ __ ] by the time the coast all move
in huh is that what you're saying
i'll have a i'll have a beachfront house
by 20.
so so you've seen the story of the uh
the two indiana boys showing up in the
news today um yeah boys are back in town
yeah well you know uh apparently there's
a book coming out uh from woodward and
costa
both the bob's the bob's
and there's an excerpt from the book
that uh it really entails a conversation
that mike pence had
with dan quayle which
the craziest part is is the lead up to
this because this is this is you know
several days before january 6 you know
it's hard to remember what happened that
day right i mean at least republicans
would find it hard to remember what the
hell never forget unless it's january 6.
right right right well that that was
kind of the craziest part about the the
911 ceremony all the ceremonies is like
oh boy this is
where
there was a terrorist attack like oh my
god well
and they were brown
yeah well right we care right well you
know what you know what the thing the
thing that's crazy and um i forget who
said this who kind of put it this way
but if you really think about this is
it's kind of eerie
like
the plane that went down in pennsylvania
like their goal
was to come and basically now no one's
really sure whether they were going to
hit the the white house or the capital
but everyone assumed the capital right
because that's like the pillar of
democracy around the world is the
capitol building
and
the taliban failed where the trump
supporters succeeded isn't that kind of
crazy
that's kind of crazy when you think
about it in that context i think though
in the long term al qaeda did succeed
ultimately their job was to
try to run the united states off of
their pedestal being the most powerful
country in the world it took some
russian help
you know we're aware of the
of the interference that was ran in 2016
uh to try to get trump to stay in office
had to be elected in the first place
but
look at you know how much money we spent
in afghanistan two trillion dollars
uh you know thousands of lives lost
and you know some
um weapons manufacturers made some money
uh over the course of 20 years but
not an inch of progress toward a more
democratic afghanistan you know i think
i think you make a really good point
because i don't know that osama bin
laden never dreamed that he would take
down the united states i think that
might have been his goal but
i i think his perspective was because
you got to remember this is a saudi with
a [ __ ] ton of money i mean it ain't like
this guy this guy is a a a broke you
know peasant in the bush it's not like
that this guy comes from a very wealthy
family um they own a lot of construction
businesses and everything else and it's
a large family so it's not like you know
this guy doesn't know world politics and
stuff like that
so i but i think you're you're getting
to the actual target here is that his
his aim was to spend our cash and to
spend our time our time and our cash and
god
did he ever
and you brought it up man i mean a lot
of what has happened what we were
fighting against uh with al qaeda has
happened here with trumpism you know
rich guys get poor people to do their
work for him and that's what osama bin
laden did with al qaeda and it's what
trump is doing with maga you know they
they send all the right signals with
god flags in the bible you know to
double up on god for for today's episode
man like you give them the right
triggers it's why the nfl has the
flyover and the flag during halftime and
before the game that's not to say that
it's not appropriate because it's a
sporting event and we've come to accept
that
but
you know you have all these images and
these things that make people
feel comfortable to go to a football
stadium even though they know it's a
super spreader event you know they're
they're protected by the faith that is
uh americana you know it's it's so
stupid like just get vaccinated take
care of your america america america you
know i i i said this today on my live
stream
that um
also all we're trying to do is force you
to make a choice because i keep saying
my body my choice and it is your choice
to get vaccinated or not i just wish you
would choose
and what i mean by that is i wish you
would choose the consequences right
because every choice has a consequence
it doesn't matter what the choice is it
doesn't matter if you think the
consequences are good or the
consequences are bad there's
consequences every goddamn choice you
make so make the choice stop
pussyfooting around stop believing the
the facebook feed store pharmacist right
with this [ __ ] ivermectin and all
this
biodeen or betadine or whatever the [ __ ]
it is stop stop stop eating horse paste
and washing it down with antiseptic that
it's not gonna cure your covet god damn
it what what you need to do is protect
your family protect your community and
protect our country by getting a vaccine
that [ __ ] works we already know that
it works and if you're terrified
that's right
and if you don't want to get it fine you
don't get to do anything that's i mean
that's my opinion but you know what what
what what the [ __ ] do i know well i
don't have the right to make other
people sick especially like kids with
disabilities noel and i were talking
about on the podcast this week there are
kids in the state of florida with
desantis who is a sociopath at this
point he's allowing people to die and
making the coven situation worse but
there are kids with disabilities whose
parents are terrified to send their kids
to school because
in a normal flu season he's already at
risk for getting sick so you add covet
into the into the mix and the santez
isn't going to mandate any kind of
mask or vaccine requirement so they're
screwing the most vulnerable vulnerable
people of our society out of education
you know and that that's what the gop
wants guys this is part of their chaos
they want a dumb populace well you know
it's crazy because uh
i and i've been saying this is that
they're they're trying to
like desantis and uh
greg abbott and some of these others it
sounds like the mississippi is the next
one up to bat for this abortion thing uh
you've seen greg abbott sign the the uh
all the bands for mass mandates they
tried to they tried to
ban banning from social media i mean
it's this anti-anti-cancer culture [ __ ]
it's just crazy but it's all it's all to
appease the the facebook fans
right it's all to appease the fans on
facebook because you know there's
nothing in reality that would that would
really make uh greg abbott think that
some of the laws that he's trying to
pass are gonna are gonna stand they're
just unconstitutional on their face and
it doesn't even make any sense but it's
all to appease the facebook fans and i
think that's what people in florida are
seeing desantis but the problem is
is some of the facebook fans in florida
that's what they want they want they're
cheering him on they're going to the
school board meetings and causing chaos
like he said
but they're not
but they don't understand dude the
reason why he wants people to get sick
is so they can get regeneron treatments
you know and then he
uh
starts to stir up the base by saying
this is the reason why
you know you're not able to go to school
and take care of your family that's what
terrorists do you know they're stirring
up a base that's already agitated you
know
we saw them trying to contest the
election before january 6th you know
imagine what's going to happen tonight
uh the chaos is going to ensue and
hopefully we can have a result this is
going to kind of be the first test to
see where our democracy is post the 2020
election and if it's even going to stand
which is kind of scary to think about
that's that's a beautiful point and i'm
glad you brought up both those topics
because both those topics are the things
we want to talk about is the january 6
and the california election so let's
start with the january 6 because now we
know
uh mr pence mike pence he was a little
he was a little uh agitated and i it
sounds like trump was really getting to
him uh one of the things that i read is
trump said i won't be your friend
anymore and uh how the [ __ ] how the [ __ ]
is it that the president and the vice
president are standing in the room
and the president's looking at him think
about this think about this as a fly in
the wall the president's looking at him
going you know what if you don't subvert
the constitution and democracy and make
sure that i'm the king and and the and
the god child of america i'm not gonna
like you anymore
and and mike pence was like oh my god
this is so bad i'm gonna call dan quail
you're not invited to my birthday party
anymore
it's my party and i can cry if i want to
so
so i was talking to someone today about
dan guell and they're like why dan quail
i'm like this makes perfect sense
i have some reasons okay well
no no let's let's hear what you're what
you why you think he called dan quayle
all right first of all
first reason he calls dan quayle
is he's terrified pence was always
terrified of trump you could see it on
his face it wasn't it didn't take any
kind of explanation to figure out that
mike pence was terrified
of trump uh and this ties into it what
kind of compromise does trump have on
mike to put him in that kind of position
to think about subverting the
constitution of the united states this
is a lifelong
official within the you know the the
constructs of our government thinking
about doing this
and the most scary aspect of this tony
is that he was seeking justification
dan quill was a former vp from indiana
uh george the first is not as extreme as
trump
but i think he was looking for a
confidant a guy who's in the same
position he was in the 80s to say
yeah go ahead and do it
you know i mean that shows you
mike pence doesn't give a [ __ ] about
democracy you know there are two vps
from indiana but only one tried to
overturn a free and fair election and
that guy is mike pence
so
yeah well so i love the point here
because i was thinking about this like
the person i was talking to on the phone
said why dan quail and i'm like well it
makes perfect sense just what you said
like
mike pence was in a situation where it
wasn't like 2000 or 2016 when
uh joe biden handed over the reigns of
power to donald trump or or al gore
handed over the reigns of power george
bush who he lost to which is kind of
similar but not the same as you lose
right right you didn't lose an
incumbency because in 1992 george george
h.w bush lost the incumbent election and
dan quayle had to hand over the power to
the person that he lost to so it makes
sense that mike pence would look for
justification and i think it was all
public right this is probably donald
trump booing him like go ask dan quayle
get dan quail get dan quayle to say this
is okay get dan because dan quayle was
in the same position you're in where he
had to hand over power to bill clinton
well the difference was is there wasn't
this idea that dan quayle was gonna
subvert democracy in the constitution he
wasn't gonna wipe his ass with the
constitution
like there was never a there was never a
whisper of that when dan quayle was
handing over the the transfer of power
and really honestly there's a video of
mike pence today um you know someone
setting him up obviously and an event
asking him about january 6 and trying to
go to him about you know why didn't you
why didn't you subvert democracy and
make trump the king and and pence says i
had no power
all we do is read the vote and count the
vote that's it
we read it record it that's it there's
he's fulfilling a duty tony there is
nothing heroic in fulfilling a duty for
the constitution you know and dan quell
for those that don't know it's a pretty
infamous clip
you know he's known for saying i i have
more experience than jack kennedy than
when when he was president you know
you doing this mike you're no jack
kennedy okay you don't even believe in
democracy and take it from a guy who has
the last name kennedy probably the most
democratic name in the history of this
country you are an embarrassment my
friend to your office and the everything
you stand for any kind of respect i had
for mike about that moment
it's gone right because because now we
know that days before he was he was
still he was still weighing the idea
that he could make trump king
now rather he could or not is the
question because i don't believe he
could i believe this idea that pence
could stand up there and do what he did
uh i i don't believe because it's all
ceremonial it's like reading the goddamn
envelope at the oscars they done won the
oscar it's done did it's just a matter
of reading the envelope and having a
little ceremony that's all that is but
you know
the legal scholars will debate that for
years and years what would happen if
mike pence would if dan quayle would
have said yeah go for a buddy but
the thing that i gets me about dan guell
is you know dank well you said he's
famous for that quote he's also famous
for not being able to spell words
and someone asked me today
the same person said well where's
dankoel from i said well he's not from
idaho because he can't spell potatoes so
he's from the state of indiana they
still both start with a our i so you
know potato potato you know type thing
but
i think that has something to do with it
too is mike pence was looking for this
this homegrown grassroots uh reason to
subvert democracy like you were saying
but because he says he says he asked dan
quayle and the quote from the story let
me let me bring it in here
um the quote from the story is it's
right here it says
uh mike you have no flexibility on this
none
zero forget it
put it away like
how more unequivocal can you get that no
absolutely not stop it
stop so
here's here's my issue tony you're the
sitting vice president of the united
states second highest like
executive uh law executive in this
country okay
you don't even make that phone call and
i'll be mad at dan quayle for a second
as a former vp you don't think that the
doj even if it was run by trump he
doesn't know somebody in there
you know like
the complicity of these former officials
and officials that were in positions of
power
it's mind-boggling like
we came so close to the american
experiment being over it's not even
hyperbole anymore we were within
minutes of it being over
you know like i just
something that it's going to keep going
it doesn't necessarily do that you know
democracy doesn't work that way so i so
that's a good point because we learn
also today that a few days after january
6. so after the coup attempt which now
we know if mike pence is calling dan
quayle to try to figure out if he can
attempt a coup or not um which i don't
know why the [ __ ] damn quail would know
that
i i still i'm still
i'm still trying to figure out exactly
what like did mike pence think dan
quayle be like no everybody calm down
he has the power to make trump king and
everyone's like oh well dan quell says
it
i mean if dan quayle says it [ __ ] it
must be true but so i'm still trying to
gather that one in my mind but
a few days after january 6 after the
coup attempt the insurrection after the
terrorists came to the capitol to try to
overthrow the government of the united
states of america
uh
mark milley the joint chief of staff
general mark billy
decides he's gonna make sure and and
people are i think are mixing the story
a little bit they they say he's there
they he uh
he he made sure trump didn't have access
to the nuclear weapons and the way i'm
reading it that isn't exactly i mean
that's an over exaggeration of what
happened because the joint chief of
staff doesn't he's not actually a
commander like they don't have authority
over
branches of government they're an
advisor role to the executive branch
right because we are
our military structure is that civilians
have control because it's a democracy
right it's a republic so that way the
military doesn't take control of our
country so that's why the joint chiefs
don't really have command orders they
can't give
command you know they're not commanders
as in they're not generals like they're
commanding the army in the pentagon
they're in an advisory role for the
president to make sure he knows what or
he or she militarily knows what's going
on or what their options are
you know
but mark milley apparently goes
and makes sure everyone understands
what protocol is here because
i think mark milley is watching the
president united states who is you know
the diaper don the cheeto dust mobster
losing his [ __ ] mind grandpa
poopypants is all over the place in the
in the white house he's talking to
sydney pal he's talking to linwood he's
talking to rudy giuliani and mike flynn
they're talking about you know the
insurrection act and all kinds of crazy
ass [ __ ] and this guy's losing his mind
he's trying to find any way he can to
sit for power and the only thing i can
think of
is that this guy brought up he can nuke
somebody or start a war and that would
keep him in power
and that's why because you see the thing
that scares me the most about the mark
millie story is not that he went and
said hey make sure you're following
protocol on these nuclear weapons
he made sure to call china and say hey
don't preemptively strike us
all the talk
all the talk in the white house that's
all talk it's all talk he's [ __ ] his
britches he's upset he needs his ass
wiped and his diaper changed don't do
not do not attack us
that is what i seen that's the kind of
the i'm putting this story together
because if you remember and i'll uh i'll
i'll get off my soapbox and let you
comment if you remember
i think it was three times
since the beginning of december that
mark millie came into in front of a
microphone and told the armed services
in public he said remember
your oath is to the constitution to the
document your oath is not to a person
your oath is not to donald trump your
oath is to the constitution like he had
to say it i think it was two or three
times that he said it and i think that
was the reiteration that he was giving
to the system after donald trump was
dismantling the pentagon dismantling the
department of defense i mean he was
really trying to do everything he could
to stay in power
yeah and he was quoted
trump
was quoted multiple times saying that he
liked acting secretaries you know he
liked shelling out our democracy and
trying to chip away at the institutions
because he knew that would make us
weaker you know he's getting all of his
commands from putin because putin is the
one that owns them you know when he
declared bankruptcy in the 1980s and 90s
nobody in america would loan him money
and it's hard to be a land developer
when you can't borrow money so you know
he became a money launderer
for the russian map and ever since then
he's been taking commands from them and
it's just
tony to see
the republican party the gop
drift away from
you know this was the party of
eisenhower you know like the
jack-booted um
you know army guy
gi joe you know that was the gop
now it's rex quando from you know
napoleon dynamite you know bow to your
should say
like that's
that's the guy for the gop now
you know and it's um
it's a sad state of affairs on one side
of the aisle brother really is well yeah
i think you're right and and um i think
that leads us into
this california election because you
brought it up earlier how important uh
these elections are because i think
you're right in that we haven't had
proof yet really electorally like how
strong this movement is because you seen
the other day in kentucky mike lindell
tried to throw a rally and it was
supposedly have like 10 000 people and
like like 300 show up and 100 of them
are like security staff that they hired
or some [ __ ] but but so they can't even
they can't even draw a [ __ ] crowd of
flies in kentucky um at this point but
but we really we need to see we need to
prove electorally uh what
how strong this movement is because i
believe it's i believe a lot of it's
[ __ ] like a lot of these school
board meetings like the objective is to
go and be as loud as you possibly can
get as many people as you can to clap to
make it feel like the entire country is
against common sense right
it's against common sense and that that
way that way everyone believes the the
[ __ ] fragility facebook fantasies
that somehow mass kill your kids and the
vaccine is gonna put a chip in you or
some dumb [ __ ] i mean it's it's hard to
even keep up with these paste eaters
anymore what they're go you know what
their next what their next facebook feed
store pharmaceutical uh prevention
products gonna be but i mean we're in a
situation in california
where you have a governor who's not
perfect i mean god damn is any
politician i'm not perfect
no
but i mean but i mean he's not he's not
destroying democracy there he's trying
to keep people safe he's trying to keep
people healthy in the state and you know
he's having a lot of pushback from these
anti-vaxxers and anti-masters and these
these these maga fools um you know but
even even with the pushback he's doing a
hell of a lot better job than greg
abbott or or desantis down in florida
um but you have this strategy
where they have this recall uh and i
think gavin newsom is gonna slam dunk
this this this recall
because he only needs 50
on the nose or 51 percent for no
for this whole thing to go away
but but you you said it earlier i think
the strategy is to question the election
question democracy itself you know i
mean i mean that's that's the test here
is
is
are they going to be successful at
saying see they steal it every time i
mean yeah i
what what they learned brother is from
roy cohn you know get your narrative out
into
the masses and then
just capitalize on it you know it's it's
what they have done
throughout the entire time all that
trump needed to declare martial law and
stay in power back uh you know in
in the 2020 election was one state to
say that there was inconsistencies with
voting you know he would have said oh
you know it's too crazy i declare
martial law and i'm in charge until
further notice you know like
it was
to say it again we were so close to the
american experiment being over
and you know it's going to be another
test tonight i'm not as worried about
california just because of how
democratic it is
but you know with the pandemic ongoing
de joy is still in charge of the postal
service you know we're going to need a
vote by mail in order for
uh you know to win these elections and
primarily that's heavily democratic so
i'm not too worried about tonight but
tonight's going to be a really good
indication for where you know 2022 and
24 are going to be i can say that i i
think you're right and i think there's a
couple things with the actual recall
election
on both on both ends of the spectrum
here because i know i know that they're
trying to so doubt uh throughout the
rest of the country and using california
to do it because california like you
said supposed to be this huge
democrat party bastion where they they
control everything which isn't exactly
the truth i mean you know
liberals or democrats control a lot of
california because californians have
common sense but uh there are there are
red parts of california there is a red
vote there and and that's why everyone
was a little nervous in the lead up to
this thing is because a person like
larry elder that [ __ ] right wing talk
show host that had fascist um he only
needs like 13 actually 13 of the vote to
become the governor of of california
which the craziest part to me and i i
don't know why california does these
recalls like this because they have
weird recall rules and the reason why is
because they have an election next year
for governor like you can get rid of
gavin newsom next year if you want to
it's not
and you know how much money they've
spent 300 million dollars right to what
to what to prove to prove what and it
shows you that our democracy has already
been bought and sold man like well so
much money being exchanged that
shouldn't be that shouldn't be happening
but you know but don't you think don't
you think though that that's the point
is is that they wanna they want to sow
doubt in people's minds about voter
fraud because the republican party knew
gavin newsom was gonna win this sure
they knew this he was i mean
of course could it happen i mean trump
was elected in 2016 but they knew he was
going to win and that was the whole
point is to say fraud fraud fraud fraud
fraud fraud fraud c
yeah even if they lose their winning
because they're going to be complaining
about it the whole time what's amazing
to me is that trump in 2016 2020 and now
his sycophants now are saying the
election's raped what are you talking
about it hasn't happened yet it's not
possible for an election to be rigged if
it hasn't happened like these gop
idiots
are complete borons they don't i mean
connect the dots folks like at this
point if you do not see what's happening
i can't help you i really don't know how
to explain it like
you're the
little bit of power that you have
is going away
and you should do everything you can to
protect it you know democracy isn't
something that's just there it has to be
maintained right we have to work for it
well and the other the other
crazy part about this election and
and really uh
what you're saying about the republican
party whining and complaining in advance
is i think this was all pre-planned this
is all part of the plan because if they
win if they win they can say c haha but
if they lose they're like oh they won
everything but don't you think long term
because i think this is the shift here a
little bit is that gop
now the gqp but the gop the republican
party has always had this long game that
they playing this is a really stupid
long game thing where they convince
their base that all elections are
already rigged
i mean i think it's a really really
really
long game it's wrong for them because i
mean eventually they could have their
base go well we never win so what the
hell is the point in voting
i mean i think that's i think that's
what has happened with the democratic
base for for decades and decades and a
lot of these red states they have such
um such erroneous
laws for you to in some of these areas
with some of these demographics to
actually vote with voter id and and
where the ballot is and how many poll
stations they have but i mean that
access to the ballot
is so limited that the democratic bases
always believe like in texas well we're
never going to win so what the [ __ ]
the point right i see that shifting and
the trump has shifted that narrative to
the republican side like oh well it's
all rigged anyway so what the [ __ ] the
difference so i think i think as long as
we can hold on to democracy here which i
have high hopes that we will but uh i
think if we can hold on to democracy
here i actually think that
it's going to be the dark ages for the
republicans and the gop
as far as as far as getting their base
to go out and vote if they've already
convinced every single one of them that
it's rigged against you they'll cancel
you it's cancer culture they'll pull
everything down they'll never let you
say anything your freedom of speech is
gone you can't vote you know that whole
narrative uh it really starts to really
starts to weigh on on your base
well and you know hopefully by this time
next year we won't be gil yet you know
that some of these things actually won't
go through
but tony i had to break it to you man
like
i think that this last election should
prove to you that there isn't that much
difference i mean sure joe biden
believes in democracy he is a big dem he
has said that he is a big government
democrat and he thinks government can
help people but you needed
uh you know
liberal republicans moderate republicans
to vote for joe biden and that's that's
what's scary about trump he went so far
right
that
democrats are like what republicans used
to be you know and
the the mediocre white man
that is rich
wants to ensure
that the rest of the populace suffers
you know so
guys like the koch brothers
uh you know these big money these
these business operations that are the
real engine to what happens in this
country those are the folks that are
wanting these voter suppression things
to take place
uh because it it hurts the rest of us
and it allows for them to make more
money it's all about money at the end of
the day well i think i think you're
right and the other thing that i think
that to add to that is that they've
convinced
the the mediocre uh maga q anon white
dude out there you know guys that look
like us that are from places that we're
from we've met a thousand of them right
we have i think i think i think they've
convinced the koch brothers donald trump
and the reason why they they think he's
such a hero is because they believe
they'll be him one day right oh i can be
like him that's why that's that's been
the whole narrative of yeah lower taxes
that way when you get rich you won't
have to pay taxes like yeah right come
on give me your [ __ ]
right and your net you're not going to
be jabezo's dude working your nine to
five and having your side gig selling
horse pace to your buddies it's not
gonna work like that you're not gonna
get rich doing that sort of thing i mean
you're not gonna be jeff bezos rich i'm
not saying that an american can't do
well and shouldn't do well it's the
american dream to be middle class right
that's the actual american dream to be
middle class not to be jeff bezos or
elon musk who the [ __ ] wants to be them
anyways
i mean i really think we should put them
back in the rockets and send them back
to outer space and take their [ __ ]
money
but
yeah yeah
another sput dick into space right right
well you know uh uh
maybe maybe if uh maybe if gas gavin
newsom wins this recall race because you
know elon musk hates gavin newsom and
hates california you know he's been
bitching about mandates and all this you
know he was losing his mind over over
quarantines and stuff last year and it's
like oh yeah the guy the guy who pays
his employees pittons and goes to space
on the the backs of his employees
are trying to go to space on the back of
his employees yeah who would have
guessed that that guy's pissed off that
his production's low and his
and but his profits are through the roof
what a dick wad what a dick one hey well
i mean man i i i think i think tax them
into oblivion did you see the did you
see the dress aoc war to the the met
gala last night did you i did not see
that you did not see this okay well i
want to see it now oh well you got to
show me now
yeah we'll look we'll look it up here
but uh
yeah the the uh the craziest the
craziest part
the craziest part about um
uh
the
the california
let's see
i'm gonna find it here sorry uh the
craziest part about the california thing
is
that
if
if i understand this right so when you
get your ballot of course i'm not in
california but i've i've watched videos
of someone it says yes or no right so
it's so easy just to vote no because
once you vote no that's it
that's it that's your vote there's no
other
you know there's not like you have to
pick someone in case [ __ ] happens you
know you just you're voting yes or no
and the reason why that's so crazy is
because if you vote no you're not
picking an alternative if there is the
recall does that make sense that's crazy
so in other words i'm saying no i don't
want to recall but because i don't want
to recall i don't get to choose who the
recall is
that's the craziest part about that
shows we need to rearrange the system
right there bro and the fact that you
have like
dianne feinstein who's you know 103 and
could die at any moment uh you know
i hope she sticks around but it's not
like congress is representative of the
of the populace you know like
um
a lot of uh
progress and or regression is dependent
on some old people
in their waning years well and and
that's the craziest part about it all is
because you give someone like larry
elder this just friggin
homophobic [ __ ] out there in in
california who loves stephen miller by
the way
you get you get a situation where you
have to you know appoint a senator
and and this guy's in love with goebbels
really holy [ __ ] can you imagine
uh that that ghoul
that ghoul
stephen miller taking a seat and
standing at the microphone on the united
states senate floor how freaking much of
a nightmare is that i don't even know if
trump being president is more of a
nightmare than [ __ ] stephen miller
being a united states senator that is
looks like smithers oh god dude
that's crazy okay i got a picture of
this dress
um see it here's the dress
that's aoc in her dress
tax the rich
right some people compared it to like
the chick-fil-a bag you know because it
it kind of looks like that but you know
here's the thing i think pisses these
people off the most is she she is
she's dude she's beautiful look at that
she is she is everything everything that
they want to be she's beautiful she has
a message and she's the best [ __ ]
troll out there ever like this pissed
this dress
pissed them the [ __ ] off dan crenshaw
was tweeting about it today like why are
you tweeting about that she has three
words written on a dress dude you are
pathetic do your job bro it shows that
they're terrified of women that's why
they're putting in these restrictions
for abortion you know they they don't
want women to be successful they hate
women that's why they want to suppress
them you know like
at this point men have screwed up the
world enough let's give women a chance
to run this thing that's the way that's
the way i look at it
that's the way i look at it i think i
think uh uh
white men in particular have [ __ ] this
whole thing up this whole situation is
[ __ ] up and if we want to hang on to
democracy if we want to have this thing
and experiment with this thing for a
couple more hundred years we should
definitely let women
full stop handle this situation and
clean this [ __ ] mess up because there
is there is no other
uh demographic of people that's going to
clean up a [ __ ] man's mess than women
and that's i think i think you're on to
something there
well uh i appreciate you joining us
buddy i really do uh in in in quick
notice uh in indiana time you know get
your neighbor uh get your neighbor on
the show mike pence how far away does he
live for me it's like uh about 20
minutes 20 minutes so he's so he's
pretty close i mean
his new his new mansion how much money
did he spend on that thing uh he's got a
couple million dollars coming in from
his book deal you know oh okay he's got
a nice crib you know he's oh giving the
good life yeah right well i mean i
wonder if he called in a loan favor for
dan quill too maybe that was the
situation he's like look if i can't be
the vice president can i get uh
you know can you grease the old skids at
a bank for me i need a house in indiana
you know if we haven't if we haven't
learned anything man the gop needs their
cut there and they're going to get it so
it well you know the grif the grift is
strong with those ones isn't it
too much too much
well thanks jimmy and and remember
everybody uh jimmy kennedy producer of
the nullcaster podcast jimmy give us
your your twitter handle there uh yeah
jbk on air twitter and instagram uh you
can check out my website jbkonair.com
all right and and you can find all that
information at jimmy's twitter account
and uh be watching we'll post some clips
from this and i'll tag jimmy in it and
you can find him go follow jimmy over
there on twitter uh keep up with the no
casler podcast thanks jimmy i do
appreciate you joining us thank you sir
always talk to you soon buddy
jimmy kennedy
the producer
of the knollcaster podcast thanks for
joining us buddy again
and
join us every week i know this is a
little strange but we're doing these
special special guest episodes where we
air them live but they've been recorded
so just to give you a rundown it's
september 14th
and the california recall election has
not happened yet
it will by the time this airs so we'll
know
if me and jimmy were right or wrong
i think we're right but we'll know we'll
know if we're right or wrong so we'll
see we're gonna air this on friday at
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern it'll come up on youtube twitter
and twitch and then it will air the
exact same time
on the podcast directories although you
already know that because you'll be
listening but any speci special guest
episodes that we do we're going to do
the same way we'll record them and we'll
we'll release them live on fridays at 3
o'clock central four o'clock eastern on
all the channels and all the directories
so thanks for joining us today and
thanks again for jimmy
coming and talking to us about those
indiana boys oh yeah
[ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me